John Rambo has been fighting his battles
on the big screen for nearly four
decades and now we're going to look at
his tale from first blood to last blood
and explain his action packed story what
little we know of John Rambo's early
life has cobbled together from various
references he and other characters have
made to it over the course of the four
films so far he grew up on his dad's
horse ranch then was drafted into the US
Army at the age of 18 after nine months
of training he was deployed to Vietnam
where he learned how to be really good
at killing and how to tie a wicked
headband bran boy became a green beret
and continued working in deep cover and
reconnaissance missions until he was
captured by the Vietcong after an ambush
and became a prisoner of war for the
next several months he was tortured
along with his comrades from Baker team
fortunately Rambo managed to escape the
powa um he returned to military service
but the deep trauma he'd suffered began
to show through in the form of a nervous
breakdown
leading to him eventually being
honorably discharged in December 1981
Rambo traveled to Washington State to
visit Delma Barry a friend from Baker
team only to be told by Berry's family
that he'd died as a result of Agent
Orange exposure
this made Rambo the last surviving
member of Baker team Baker team they're
all dirt sir
it was gone too soon Rambow moved on and
won that into the nearby town of hope
but a local sheriff while teasel try to
quickly assure him out of town for fear
that had caused trouble rambo who was
just looking for something two weeks
went back into hope anyway leading
Teasle to arrest him Cecil's deputies
began harassing and threatening Rambo at
the station using his Green Beret skills
Rambo forces way out to the station
before making his getaway on a stolen
motorcycle in the ensuing search to
t---cells deputy articles began firing
at Rambo from a helicopter
Rambo retaliated by hurling a rock of
the chopper after results the helicopter
pilots lost control and gold fell to his
death yeah it was self-defense but now
he was wanted for killing a cop dismayed
over the death of gold too Rambo tried
to convince Teasle that it was an
accident
and he begged the sheriff for no more
trouble he's so driven to rage by the
loss of his friend continued the fight
at Rambo incapacitated his deputies in
the woods the National Guard arrived to
help with the search and with them came
Colonel Trautman mumbos former
commanding officer I didn't come here to
rescue ramble from you I came here to
rescue you from him with a manhunt
ramping up the National Guard troops
went as far as blowing up an abandoned
mine that tried to kill Rambo but he
escaped into the town of Hope in pursuit
of Teasle Troutman intervened and tried
to convince Rambo to surrender causing
Rambo to break down in tears weeping and
grieving the veteran poured out or the
horrors at experience during and after
the war with Troutman's help
Rambo surrendered to the authorities
peacefully and the great warrior was
ultimately sentenced to hard labor in
prison
Rambo spend the next four years in
prison but that'll change when Colonel
Trautman returns and offered him a
presidential pardon and his freedom in
exchange Rambo would have to assist in
an operation to confirm reports of
American prisoners still being held in
Vietnam under the supervision of marshal
Murdock Rambo reluctantly agreed to this
but the mission was rocky from the start
when Rambo spotted an American prisoner
tied up out in the open he disobeyed
orders and rescued him in the ensuing
battle Rambo destroyed a Vietnamese
gunboats
and as for extraction by American forces
Murdock fearing a scandal if the
American public found out about the
remaining prisoners being left in
Vietnam left a Rambo to be captured by
the Vietnamese and their Russian allies
of course Rambo ultimately escaped and
freed all the prisoners of the
when he returned to the American Bay to
the POWs Rambo immediately made for
Murdock's office a machine guns entire
command center in classic Rambo fashion
then he went after Murdock had left him
to die Troutman intervened and asked
Rambo to walk away and take his
government pardoned Rambo once again
feeling betrayed by his country's
treatment of its soldiers spared
Murdock's life but he didn't return to
America three years after things went
crazy in Vietnam Colonel Trautman truck
down Rambo who was living in a kind of
self-imposed exile in Thailand Trotman
Astron bo for helping a CIA mission to
provide a to Afghan fighters battling
the Soviets Rambo declined but when
Troutman was captured in Afghanistan
Rambo decided to embark on a rescue
mission he headed over to Afghanistan to
infiltrate the Soviet base where
Troutman was being held he was able to
rescue Troutman but Soviet colonel yeh
soon launched a pursuit determined to
kill Rambo and Troutman both after
commandeering a Soviet tank Rambo killed
Zaisan and the world's most epic game of
chicken with the battle worm Rambo and
Troutman left Afghanistan together and
Rambo ultimately returned to isolation
in Thailand around 20 years passed after
the incident in Afghanistan and during
all that time John Rambo managed to
maintain his quiet life in Thailand
earning a small living by catching and
selling snakes and transporting people
on his boat but that all changed when a
group of missionaries from Colorado
asked if he would take them into Burma
to provide humanitarian aid Rambo was
reluctant he's like it's a war zone up
there but he agreed after one of the
missionaries Sara Miller
convinced him that they could make a
difference and he's like you Boogaloo
weapons Rambo dropped the missionaries
off in Burma only to later be approached
by the minister who informed them of
their capture by government soldiers
amid a mass slaughter a big softie a
heart Rambo agreed to aid a group of
mercenaries hired by the church to
rescue the missionaries and obviously
things got super bloody in the middle of
a fierce firefight Rambo pretty much
single-handedly rescued the mercenaries
and the missionaries from essentially
every bad guy in Burma after rescuing
Sara Rambo took a message of kindness to
Hut's
and he returned home to Arizona to visit
his father for the first time in many
years
Rambo last blood will pick up roughly a
decade after the events of Rambo
and while the film hasn't been released
yet we do know a few things about the
plot rambo seems to have stayed in
arizona and he's made at least some kind
of peace with its existence their last
blood will feature Rambo's niece in
peril after she's abducted by a Mexican
cartel in an effort to get her back at
all costs
Rambo will revisit his old combat skills
one last time heading into Mexico to
battle the cartel we don't yet know
exactly how that will unfold
how much will learn about Rambo's home
and family life or how well he's dealing
with his past trauma but we do know two
things for sure
first Rambo last blood will hit theaters
on September 20 years 2019 second there
will definitely be some more blood check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos but your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]